[Applause]
Steve I think you can tell people are
glad to see you back
very friendly Thanks well let me just
start with kind of an opening question
and I'll ask a few and then we'll
actually turn to our students for the
real hard balls okay but let me just ask
you to say a little bit about Microsoft
you reach a new Plateau now you've
launched Vista and a new version of the
office and of course you've got some
interesting challenges you've got Linux
in the enterprise you've got Apple and
Google and the consumer space and so
maybe the best opener would be just take
a few minutes and tell us you know how
you see the company in the state of play
and some of the opportunities and
challenges right now yeah you know a lot
of questions I get asked a lot is it
sounds like camera mode a silly question
in a sense and very important question
others what what is Microsoft you know
we we software company are we just the
windows company what are we trying to do
what are our goals what our aspirations
what do we want to be when we grow up in
the sense and you know we our core
competences writing software that really
is the thing that we know how to do we
write software for very kind of broad
horizontal things but then how to apply
that how to think about it very
important now if you ask what are the
things that I think characterize our
company and sort of really talk to the
issues you're talking about number one
we're fundamental believer that the
power of software is going to continue
to positively transform society we just
did something we wrote down 70
technologies that are gonna change the
world over the next five or six years
Bill Gates and the team of our technical
guys drove down actually when they first
came back with him I said you're not
allowed to have 70 of them you know I'm
a kind of more simple-minded guy give me
five bill said no we spend seven billion
on R&D I want to at least have a hundred
million on each I get 70 and
and I remember that from math camp so to
speak don't work so you know and yet and
when you stop and think about it the
future of the way people interact kind
of with their televisions the future of
reading how many people read on paper
how many people don't why what does the
technology have to do to change and
morph the future of the way software
programs get developed we just bought a
company down here that's in the speech
recognition area the future of speech is
a technology there's so much innovation
and and and and to get excited about
that's the kind of the who we are and
the good news is there's plenty of
opportunity from a business perspective
if we just kind of follow our noses on
the kind of interesting innovations that
are out there in a business sense we're
actually now the point where I kind of
think of us as having to have four
different business muscles all around
this technology we grew up is kind of a
PC desktop company never was quite sure
what anybody meant by it but people
always told us you're a desktop company
over the last 17 18 years we've tried to
be an enterprise company and you know
people think of the IBM's and the
Oracles of the world now we're trying to
build two new muscles we're trying to be
a what I call modern consumer
electronics company a company that does
consumer devices where software's the
hero with hardware into woven as opposed
to the old-style consumer electronics
where hardware was the hero and you
might put a little software in and we're
also focused on being an Internet
information and advertising company and
you used the word Plateau I I sort of
don't see a plateau we finally reached a
milestone took us a little longer than
we'd like to ship this Windows Vista
product but it's in the market and sort
of in a sense we've enabled for
ourselves the next generation of growth
in some cases it's very obvious how we
pursue our market continues to grow good
for the PC industry we're moving into
new areas where we have new competitors
in the enterprise space you mentioned a
couple of them in your in your question
you know in the consumer electronics
area Xbox taking off internet TV taking
off both
for us challenges with some of the other
competitors I always love to remind our
shareholders that areas where we don't
have share we can probably build more
market captain areas where we already
have high chair so in a sense I see kind
of a positive in all of in all of these
areas I got asked the other day by an
investor and maybe I'll kind of
summarize you know the answer your
question are you a growth company which
there's probably folks who've been
vested money professionally in the
audience I never have so idea what is a
growth company what's a growth company I
don't know is a growth company company
that's investing in the future then I
said we're a growth company and so I
said what do you call growth company she
says well you got to grow 13% a year I
said what do we have to grow 13 percent
a year growing 13 percent of years
premium if you mean revenue do we have
to go revenues 13 percent of you she's
no no I guess I didn't really mean that
I said all we'll do is we'll just sell
more hardware we won't make any more
money but we can grow our revenues 30 no
no no not revenue and I said well well
then what she said I said you want
operating income to grow 13 percent a
year or EPS it's actually easier to grow
EPS than it is operating income because
you get to buy back your stock and do
all that kind of stuff
all that financial stuff mostly second
year stuff excellent and she finally
said no you gotta grow your operating
income not thirteen percent a year I
said okay well at least now I know what
the test is I'm not going to tell you
whether I'm gonna make it or not
forward-looking statements don't make
those blah blah blah then I said let's
just say 13% for three years we make
about twenty billion dollars of
operating income so that means we'd have
to grow operating income by about ten
billion dollars in the next three years
I don't know how many people in the room
try to name a company in the world that
makes ten billion dollars of operating
income that's not in oil and is not in
financial services you you will you'll
get some but you'll be hard-pressed to
get there very quickly
and I said so you want us to grow a
whole ten billion and I said I can't I
can't make that commitment but I can say
there's plenty of opportunity and what
we do and so we're not really at a new
Plateau I think we're at a new jumping
kind of jumping off spot so
interestingly some of these new growth
markets do not have their foundation in
the Windows platform which has been your
historic source of growth and success so
what have you learned about competing
and markets where Windows isn't your
fundamental de facto platform to start
with in a way what I would say is our
core platform is the technology base we
provide and let me just take Xbox I
don't know whose Windows not part of the
gaming market I think that would be
consistent with your question and yet we
use exactly the same graphics system
essentially for people to write video
games that we use that allows Toyota to
design and model next-generation
automobiles so we're not using
necessarily the same brand and same
image but we do get a chance to read use
technology and in a sense one if you're
in a company that's really an R&D driven
company once you've spent an eye R and D
dollar you've got to sell the R&D to
everybody
there's just especially in our business
there's just no marginal cost so if we
spend dollar
on graphic systems we ought to sell it
to people in PC desktops we ought to
sell it to it in scientific rendering
farms we ought to sell it to people in
video game machines we ought to sell it
every place that its popular and that's
why it's really driven us to work on
these for business models here people
said Windows was a boat anchor in a
sense for us as we attack the enterprise
because we were just a little old
desktop company well today we've got you
know business that's close to 10 billion
dollars in enterprise software and
windows and all those technologies were
helpful and I think the same thing can
be true in the online world I think the
same thing can be true in this kind of
modern consumer electronics business so
moving a little bit from strategy to
organization I've read recently that you
set up a system of three presidents on
the major businesses but I've also read
that Steve you're a really hands-on guy
you love to dig into the data and the
numbers so what's it like being one of
your presidents and how do you actually
operate with these three folks and still
keep yourself informed yeah if you
actually ask because they're enough to
do without micromanaging every detail I
guarantee we have no shortage of things
that need to be done and one of the
things I think people miss when they
think about this is just how how
complicated any large organization is
the Stanford GSB Microsoft any financial
and services institution you know when I
think about my agenda I have to
represent the company externally but
that's thirty thirty five percent of my
cut time right there
whether it's speeches like this customer
calls people want to see the CEO that's
a third of might of my time I have a
roughly a third of my time that is tied
up really in what I would call coaching
mentoring people formal management
meetings operating meetings where we do
review strategy or people or or
execution and the businesses that report
to me board meetings recruiting meetings
I'll go out and you know try to help
recruit pee
full one-on-ones let's all call that
time that I can't micromanage people but
where I can help
and then about a third of the time I
actually get to work on things which I
want to focus on and generally I will
tend to focus on things which are big
growth opportunities or which are tough
strategic challenges and you know in
every one of our businesses we probably
have one or two things that fall into
that category and I'll spend most of my
time with those leaders and with their
teams in those areas and and that seems
to be okay
but it is not like you know I I can
honestly say I think I'm the only person
that can say they've either been the
number one or number two guy in
companies from all sizes between 24 and
75,000 I don't think you can find
anybody else and will tell you that
they've basically run companies of all
those sizes and I will today there does
come a point where there's a point where
you think you can know everything that's
going on and then there's a point where
you discovered you stop knowing
everything that was going on really
three years earlier and you got to
evolve to a new approach and we've kind
of hit that about 1998-1999 in my case I
didn't even pretend I do everything I
thought I knew the business side and I
thought bill knew the technical side
probably around 97 things really had
already morphed and we probably figured
that out by about 98 and 99 and now we
you know sort of systematically been
building around teams that really drive
this stuff and trying to add extra value
as opposed to everything else so
listening to your breakup of time an
awful lot of it you might call
leadership and people management and
could you perhaps share a little bit
some of your own personal insights about
leadership and managing people yeah
there are two or three things which I
think are most important for leaders to
do and yet don't always focus on them
very well everybody likes to say leaders
have to insist on accountability and
that's right but there's a yin and the
yang to that too you want to insist on
accountability but you also want to
insist that people stretch themselves
and push themselves
if the game is I got done what I said I
could do and you're really rigorous
about that you'll encourage people to
set their goals low and so how do you
manage the yin and the yang of
stretching people and yet at the same
time holding them accountable that's
sort of a key a key leadership dimension
how do you manage the yin and yang of
wanting to sort of delegate and yet
knowing enough of the details that
you're an intelligent participant in the
decisions the funding the key the key
issues that that your your people are
involved with I can't say I'm going to
know nothing about most of our
businesses and yet I don't want to
micromanage our businesses and how do
you hit hit that blend businesses are
complicated that is true and yet leaders
have to deal with the yin and yang of
the fact that things are complicated yet
one of the leaders great value adds is
simplifying things the truth of the
matter is the perspective that you get
the more you're at the 50,000 foot
levels to try to be able to say here are
the three or four things that really
matter the key principles and yet not
make them seem so you know mom and apple
pie is to be meaningless and a lot of
the times we have problems with leaders
the leaders simply aren't trying to
simplify they're trying to show they
understand the full complexity of the
situation and leaders really do need to
hit the exact right balance on what I'd
call the optimism realism curve if
you're not realistic you lose respect
from customers partners shareholders
press employees if you're not realistic
but if the leader can't be optimistic if
the leader can't say life is going to be
better we're gonna take shared we're
gonna improve this situation if you
can't sort of handle being optimistic
and realistic at the same time I think
it's tough to be a great leader so
that's probably those four leadership
perspectives that with my guys I wind up
spending the most time on is getting the
right balance for for them for me on
those kind of four dimensions so as you
mentioned
you've been there now going from 24
people to 75,000 people there was
clearly a time when you were well known
for being the place to be you know this
is the place to join innovative young
entrepreneurial company now as you
compete with people like ya yahoo and
google and apple certainly familiar
names around here how do you keep the
place innovative exciting at
seventy-five thousand versus when you
were twenty four yeah one is how do you
continue to get the best and the
brightest fact is we just finished our
best recruiting year ever and you know
i'm very proud of that excited about
that yet there's more recruiting
competition than there's been in a long
time economy's good you know
particularly here in the valley things
are good hedge funds want programmers
these days it's kind of a pain in the
neck for those of us who have that who
didn't have the financial services
industry impeding on our our issues so
getting the best people remains a big
issue for us and you know you could say
just as windows deserved a competitor
and we got one in linux so did microsoft
for talent deserve a competitor and
we've got one at least sort of showcase
competitor from talent that's okay it's
kind of like linux people said it would
wipe us out did it wipe us out no in
fact our market shares today are
stronger than they were three or four
years ago and same thing in the hunt for
talent you got to put your head down
you've got to say we're gonna work at it
we got a compelling proposition if you
want to work on the broadest set of kind
of interesting ways to transform the
world through technology there's no
better place to work than Microsoft
that's a fact if you want to engage in
broad innovation there really is no
better place to be now some people
actually think it's innovative to work
on the next generation of development
tools and some people don't and I pick
something that sounds really techy and
da-da-da-da-da but there will be
breakthroughs in the next ten years and
the way software gets created and
somebody's going to make a lot of money
out of that somebody's going to show a
lot of innovation out of that we're
about the only place on the planet that
people are pushing that agenda as
aggressively as I think it ought to be
as it ought to be put the truth is a lot
of people flee people coming right out
of school love consumer products and you
know you got to be hot with the consumer
products Apple's done a nice job with
iPod we'll see how they do with iPhone I
don't know you know we've done a nice
job with Xbox but we have a few Xbox
enthusiasts here in the audience and our
foam product is now starting to get some
real traction Google's obviously done a
nice job with their search product but
frankly I've had a hard time getting
traction in some of the other areas and
so on the consumer side we're all just
out there kind of really working to earn
our chops and I will tell one thing I
have learned all companies start out
young and age turns out every year every
company is one year older than it was
the year before and that's another
quantitative skill it's the truth is
great companies have to figure out how
to remain vibrant despite the fact that
they don't remain essentially run
necessarily by 24 and 25 year olds I
always tell our people what's the brand
we should aspire to that's been around
for a long time and yet people think of
it as kind of a leadership dynamic brand
and it's hard to point a lot of us
because there's a sort of a I don't know
natural disruption but you know I guess
I can point to two of my almost alma
mater the brand of Harvard the brand of
Stanford and education those have been
good and sort of dynamic brands
leadership brands for many many years
and in some senses I think that's what
great companies have to aspire to is
brands and and brands are made by the
product and services that you offer
that you want to keep them great you
know not just for 10 years 15 years 20
years but really out into the future and
we're gonna try to stay as dynamic as as
any institution in the world and some
people would also say that brand is a
product of your culture we hear so much
about company culture what what's the
culture of Microsoft like in your view
and what do you do as
the CEO to try to change it or nurture
it or strengthen it and what's your role
yeah we have kind of two personal
characteristics and six values that we
think a lot about the personal
characteristics we like people were very
bright and very intense very bright very
intense very bright very attentive and
unlike you I think that that's part of
the culture and you know you get good
and bad with that you can prioritize I
mean you might say doesn't every company
prioritize those two things I think the
answer is no we we do and our culture
reflects that but we also have integrity
as a core value for a company and I
think it's just important you always
have to remind yourself about that
accountability is a core value of the
company we want people making big bold
bets it's ironic people are saying are
you are you gonna innovate
who else would try something as you know
nutty as we did when we set out to do
xbox a big ball bet but not too many
people would have made and yet we made
it and so there's a collaboration
dedication to making others better
that's one where our culture needs
ongoing nurturing and improvement and
evolution and we've done it I think a
really good job outside with our
business partners with the complexity of
our R&D process we also need to have
that same kind of collaboration inside
so there's some things like that that I
would say are hallmarks and characterize
our place the desire for to change the
world also means we want lots of
customers winning to us instead of
measured in the number of customers we
have versus the number of people who
engage in any activity there's on the
planet about 10 million software
developers I want them all using our
tools that's kind of what we come to
work in any game we find someone who's
not it's interesting yes why not
why why what about this what about this
what would it take what do we have to
take is it price as it features as a
capability is that innovation you know
that's that's a part of our culture and
what in particular do you do perhaps to
keep strengthening that how do you
there are there things that you do
behaviorally or where you spend your
time and you were talking earlier about
a third a third a third and that is you
can you break that out at all in terms
of reinforcing these things basically I
didn't know this I didn't know this even
when I became CEO I'll say that which
was seven years ago everything I do is a
reinforcement or not of what we want to
have happen culturally you name an
activity I did I did three things so far
today I gave a speech in 2qa with 200
venture capitalists down in our campus I
gave a speech to about 700 of our
employees I had a one-on-one meeting
with you and I'm here every one of those
things sends a message it's we have Pete
Microsoft employees in the audience we
have recruits we've got interns
everything here is communicating about
us and either reinforcing or not
reinforcing what we want to do
culturally when we meet with the VCS
everything there is going to reinforce
what their portfolio companies have a
chance to think about it so I have to
think everything we do is actually a
teaching and learning exercise in what
we believe in what our culture is what
our values are
etc and could you comment a little bit
you said I didn't know that even when I
became CEO and what is there about not
being CEO or then becoming CEO and you
see that do you think okay I should have
known exactly what the job of CEO was
when I took it I mean I worked with Bill
for 20 years before he asked me to be
CEO and we were partners we're doing
everything together and yet two things
substantively change when you become CEO
number one you really do have
bottom-line accountability and you will
feel it in different ways then when
you're not CEO as you know and number
two really the tone at the top in terms
of culture and values and what's
important that is not eligible you can
coach other people but the culture and
transformation and standing up for it
and believing in it and teaching in it
that starts with the CEO and so one
thing you can
delegate you can delegate everything you
want in finance you can delegate
everything you want to in marketing you
can even delegate many things that you
in strategy
you cannot delegate culture ok enough
for the easy questions let's open it up
and who wants to go first and we'll do
as many as we can
yeah and I'm really curious about how
you made the decision to drop out of
Stanford and join Microsoft you know
what you saw in them and how you were
thinking about that decision and how
exactly it's happened yeah I was I was
trying to decide actually what to do for
my first year summer job I was about you
know I basically go and I had stayed in
touch after I got out of Harvard I went
visited him first time I ever been in
Seattle was the summer before I started
at the GSB because Seattle it's kind of
off the end of the earth at least it
felt that way back then and so we'd
stayed in touch I was going through the
first year I love the first year it's
great I was learning a lot of stuff
wonder what I would have learned that
second year I really do but you know how
to be a CEO and I was trying to decide
what to do for summer job and I'm
basically in my mind I had four good
thoughts
one was to join a consulting firm still
a popular option one was to join Morgan
Stanley
still a good option I suppose I was
looking at progressive insurance which
was a relatively small insurer then
quite large now but I'd gotten to know
the president when he interviewed me as
an undergraduate at Harvard and they
were offering me kind of an assistant to
the president
job that sounded kind of exciting to me
and and then it was looking at Ford
Motor Company because I'm from Detroit
my dad was with Ford the then CEO I
think was a Stanford GSB alum a guy
named Don Peterson and so I'm trying to
decide what to do for the summer and
normally I guess you don't fly back and
visit everybody for summer jobs but for
a variety of reasons I was had a week
scheduled on spring break I was going to
go see all these guys back in their home
so Mackenzie I was gonna go visit in
Chicago and Morgan Stanley and I went to
Boston to see Bain in BCG I went home to
see Ford I wasn't going back to
Cleveland no offense to Cleveland but I
just didn't have that as a stopping
point and Phil gave me in constant hey
what are you what are you doing I said
well you know it's a two-year program he
says yeah it's too bad it's too bad
maybe you should come up here no you'd
have to leave he said hey yeah too bad
you don't have a twin brother we could
kind of use somebody like you around
here now yeah yeah I thought about it
for day I said well Bill's the smartest
guy I'd ever met and I always liked the
idea I mean I wanted to work for smart
people and I didn't have that uniformly
in my Procter & Gamble experience I had
it but not uniformly so really smart and
I
I didn't know much about the business
I'd written a few programs in my life
but I knew they were the world leader at
an emerging thing that's about really
all I knew about the business and you
know Bill and I talked about it but I
was no expert and so I said I called him
back and said hey why don't I
why don't I end my trip to see all these
summer job companies I've come to
Seattle and see you and so I did I came
in I talked to Bill I talked to Paul
Allen who was his partner
bill had his mom and dad worked me over
which was the standard recruiting trick
and all days his dad's like six seven
and quite an imposing figure bill
actually left me and Seattle by myself
he was going on vacation for the first
time so he kind of LKC Steve enjoyed my
house try to lock the door when you
leave and I thought about it and decided
yeah we bill and I agreed we try it it
didn't work out I could quit or he could
fire me at the end of the summer and I'd
come back to Stanford so I went and
talked to the folks in administration
they said that's okay we'll take you
back are you sure this is a good
decision are you sure this is a wise
decision
I called my dad who thought I was just
about the craziest well my dad thought
it was nuts completely nuts you know
Microsoft what's that what is it you
know what - might not what software's my
mom said why does anybody need a
computer this is Mike it's 1980 and my
dad my dad was an immigrant and he
didn't go to college and so he thought
it was sort of triple buddy and he had
worked at Ford where everybody had my
dad thought it was nutty when I went to
Stanford because mostly guys he knew at
Harvard had at Ford had Harvard MBAs and
he had to check it out and when he found
out this guy Don Peterson was ok
Stanford's okay so my dad was now that
was the toughest call I ever made in my
life but I went on up to Microsoft and
after six weeks I decided I'd made a
real mistake and I should come back for
the second year of Business School and I
told Bill and he said Steve Steve Steve
[Music]
lets you and me in my dad go out and
forget it
so we did and a dinner bill said to me
look you don't get it you may feel like
you just joined to become the bookkeeper
of a 30-person company but we're gonna
put a computer on every desk in every
home and I swear that recruiting pitch
to KITT keep me wound up being the
mantra of the company basically for the
next 17 18 years three weeks later I
bought a house in Seattle and I
cherished my first year was a lot of fun
I actually did learn a lot that was
pretty important I go to all my reunions
people seem to forgive me not having
finished the second year and if any of
you find something that you have the
same kind of passion and enthusiasm and
excitement for see Dean Johnson
they worked out pretty well well there
seems to be two notions in there maybe
you had them woven together and I have
our time
there's entrepreneurship whatever that
means and there's growth and whatever
that means you know yes we went from 24
to 75,000 people over 27 years and if
you did a compound growth rate and head
count you'd get a relatively low number
it's just a lot of years and it's very
consistent I think with the particular
competitor you mentioned they're trying
to double in a year I think that's that
that's insane my opinion doesn't mean
they won't do it well but we've been
digesting a certain percent growth over
many years and what that's allowed us to
do is to build up a base of capable
people who can take on more capable
people I don't really know that anybody
is proven but a random collection of
people doing their own thing actually
creates value all of them no I'm not
look I'm not until until the scenario
plays out let's just say it hasn't
played out Google's builds one very good
business okay but they only have one
thing that they do everything else is
sort of cute but there's one thing no
come on we do a lot of cute things too
I'll tell you about our robotics effort
but it's not paying for me to come down
to the Stanford Business School
I call us I like to refer to us as a to
trick pony and to trick ponies are rare
in the history of business desktop was a
trick and server was a trick the third
trick we're trying to do online the
fourth trick we're trying to do consumer
electronics but you know and you can
fill things in around that and you'll we
filled on a lot of things around the
desktop windows and the applications
windows server and the database and
Google's trying to fill some things in
around their basic footprint but they're
still really one business and it's a
search and advertising business and ok
great and it's grown at a certain speed
in fact they've grown faster to you know
the 10 billion mark then we got to the
10 billion mark but that just says the
industry was ready for that to happen
and good things have happened so
entrepreneurship to me is more about
your ability to fill in through your own
smart efforts and about going to do the
second or third or fourth trip and so in
some senses growth theory there's really
four stages to business one is I invent
something it may or may never take off
to is I get something to critical mass
three is I milk it like heck when it's a
critical mass
for I create a culture in which I can do
one again and I'm also prepared to go
out I or anybody else we all have to be
prepared to go out and acquire and start
the loop again great companies wind up
having to be all for most companies
don't ever get out of the I have an idea
and get it to critical mass stage some
people get to critical mass and are
never able to really let me say milk the
idea those typically tend to get sold
off and some people can't regenerate
themselves entrepreneurship to me is as
much about all four parts of the cycle
or the first and second in the fourth
right now you know Google's in this part
of the cycle where they're milking
effectively I love it's a fun part of
business hey we've got something good
going
come on pom pom you follow your
customers you do all that innovators
dilemma stuff you just keep following
your customers collecting money hey
twenty percent twenty percent we don't
have to do anything new we just got to
do it twenty percent more next year you
know that was our 90s that was the 90s
for us and are they I would say the 80s
in the 90s and now we're really in the
phase where you have to say look we got
a we got a we got a loop again and our
server business was really like a whole
separate process and we're gonna do it
again and we're gonna do it again and
it's not just a question of the
technology innovation it's also the
ability to embrace multiple business
models you know when people say is this
a growth company they could be asking
one of two questions does the model you
have continue to grow over the next
several years or number two do we
believe that you'll invent new models of
growth and great companies probably have
to be able to do both very well when I
think about General Electric and the
thing that I think people ought to think
about is brilliant about General
Electric they do both and they're very
few Proctor and Gamble
they do both and they've been able to do
both over a consistent period of time a
lot of financial services companies you
point goldman sachs for example they do
both and so the ability to do both
these things very well they're both
aspects of entrepreneurship and so some
of its about invention and some of its
about about growth but those are almost
different things okay taught by Eric
Schmidt at Google but in actually that
class you know there's a theme of that
A's higher A's and B's higher seas and
also the importance of mentorship and
you've been kind of the first you know
business hire and continuing to be at
the top of the organization
I mean who did you get your mentorship
from and in the areas that you need to
develop where did you look - because you
were actually at the top all from the
beginning to the end to the degree I got
quote mentorship I would got it from
Bill I mean not you know Bill was a just
an incredible Bill Gates was just an
incredible source of learning and
education for me when I joined not not
about leadership and business business
so much is about the technology Bill's
an incredible strategy thinker
incredible strategy business strategy
thinker in addition to an innovator but
I would say I got most of my mentorship
by being able to study other companies
you know our business is built in
conjunction with partners and customers
I can tell you during the decade of the
1980s I probably understood what was
going on at IBM as a company as well as
anybody who worked there what was
working from a leadership perspective
what wasn't working because I would
basically probably you know 25-30
percent of my time is with IBM I learned
a lot from IBM we spent a lot of time
with Intel you can learn a lot of good
things in a in a way by studying and
asking questions and even to this day if
I really want to engage that way I'll
just ask other people how they do things
when Jeff Immelt and I get together
we're always saying how do you do this
what do you do about that Miles White
was a guy who was ahead of me one year
at the GSB I ran into him last weekend
he runs Abbott Labs how do you do this
what do you do about that you're bored
you try to add people to boards of
directors we've got the former CEO of
BMW former CEO of Merck you know how do
you handle
things so everybody turns out wants to
help you bro if you're willing to engage
with a lot of people I didn't have
anybody I'd point to those a single kind
of a mentor other than Bill Gates just
trying to be fair here up the Mac yeah
right when you talk about the trade-off
you faced along your career on a
personal level and what continues to be
a greatest personal challenge today time
there's no doubt time is the greatest
personal challenge when I tell you what
percentage of my time is in every areas
because I have a detailed spreadsheet I
allocate this is the amount of time I
travel this is the amount of time I'm
home this is the amount of time I do
this and you know it's got about you
know probably about thirty five rows in
it each with a very specific budget a
nights away budget that I kind of
negotiate with myself my kids and my
wife every year because we have three
youngest kids and you know I'll tell you
I work hard to be able to drop the kids
off in the morning at school slashed the
bus and I'm home in time for dinner my
wife which I'm home in time for dessert
some cognitive dissidence about that I
would say but the number one trade off
on the personal front it's not like I'm
a person with a lot of hobbies I mean I
run in the morning because I need to or
I gain weight I wouldn't call it a hobby
I because I like to have one thing that
I do and I've got my family and I've got
my work and that's that's it for me and
that that works for me that works just
fine but then I just try to balance the
time between the two okay right here in
the middle both you and Microsoft are
going through a pretty unique phase
right now the transition of Bill Gates
and I was running if you could talk
about that transition what was the first
thing that came to your mind when Bill
told you Steve I'm taking off and how
I'm sort of manage that whole process
going forward yeah I mean in a way it's
been more gradual than that because it
goes back to 97 I think when Bill's
first started talking about having me be
president and so we went through a
thought process in transition and then
Bill talked to me in late 99 no he
missed out 98 about being president and
then 99 about taking over CEO and that
was a big transition for for Bill and
for me and then a few years ago three
years ago now almost I started talking
to me about the notion of not being
full-time
it was to be part-time at Microsoft but
not being full-time and that was a less
I mean it in a public sense it felt like
it was a bigger deal but I felt more
prepared frankly for that transition and
the transition to CEO a few years before
we're working on that in a few ways
number one
were you know Bill and I agreed
explicitly he's got to go from being
leader to coach in some places where he
would have thought of himself as having
to lead the activity he's the coach of
the activity we're trying to moderate
his external engagement so the
partnerships that he was primary on were
transitioning the other folks which we
made sure we put the leadership
structure in place two years before he
took off so that folks who were picking
up part of Bill's mission have a chance
to be coached and learn about that part
of their work very explicitly ray I see
four examples our chief Software
Architect I'm having a chance to
go through that because there were sort
of strategy priorities that bill is
focused in on that I have anything bill
is really focused in on I have never
focused in on anything I'm really
focused in on bills not we view
ourselves as sort of close enough as a
partnership group one of the things I
didn't think about as explicitly as I
probably should have is it's nice to
have a partner anybody running a larger
organization it's nice to have somebody
who you can really talk to like a
partner bill and I've had that for 27
years and now I'm forging kind of a new
a new set of partnerships and that's
been probably the biggest transition for
me you know with Bill it's easy you
cannot replace Bill Gates you can run a
great company but you shouldn't think
you're gonna replace a guy who's a
founder a guy who knows where most of
the stones are unturned a guy who's the
smarter guys I've ever met in my life a
guy who's as famous as any guy I've ever
met in my life no seriously you can't
say let's plug compatibly okay we have
another Bill Gates shirt you know run
him into the job you can't think about
it that way
it's wrong-minded there was a book we
had to read when I was in college
sections of a book by this guy mots
Weber about the routinization of
charisma and it talked about transitions
from quote charismatic leaders and how
those go I went out a gust I've dusted
the book back off I reread it was
actually quite helpful to think about
and you see a lot of great institutions
that have managed to routinize after
charismatic leaders I mean China kind of
went through this from Mao tse-tung's
through to you know the present day
leadership you could have great things
happen after great leaders but you got
to think about it and be explicit about
it yes right here
yeah I think you have to to say there's
probably two kinds of development that
people go through there are people who
are really functional in their approach
we're trying to develop people as
salespeople as marketing people as
finance people when you get through a
company that's got 75,000 people in it
at least a reasonable percentage of the
people never want to be never will be
general managers and then there's a set
of people who really do want to be and
you've got to make sure that you give
the right kind of development
opportunities to each one of them you
know you cannot run a very large company
that's got operational processes without
having some people who may not have the
same general management aspirations that
others do I'd say we have a higher
percentage of what I call high
aspiration employees than then almost
any 75,000 person company in the world
on the other hand it's still not a
hundred percent of our employee base so
we've worked really hard to give people
both functional development as well as
what I would call more general either
general management or strategy
management we have a bunch of engineers
who never actually want to be general
managers but actually do want to be the
strategy drivers for businesses and we
need to give them kind of the best of
it's not technology development but they
need to get some strategy and general
management development even though they
don't ever want to really manage people
some of our most influential people
manage no one and so we really have the
three models that we work on and think
about in terms of development everybody
who joins out of Business School
basically wants to be a general manager
of some form or a senior manager if not
a general manager that that would be
almost uniformly true but if you join us
as a sales rep in you know Philadelphia
your grand goal in life might be to be a
better paid sales rep in Philadelphia
and we want to make sure we nurture that
person in their career desires as
much as we do the newly minted Stanford
MBA I sleep very well well I mean I
actually do sleep very well you know it
gets back to the issue I was talking
about in terms of realism and optimism
you have to be realistic so it doesn't
mean everything's always going well or
that there's no threats no clouds on the
horizon but I do have a fundamental
optimism about areas where we're weak
we're gonna get strong areas where we're
strong we're gonna get stronger people
we want to get we're gonna get I do have
a fundamental optimism about that
I'd say the things that eat at me the
most tend to fall into two categories
number one is new business model
learning new business model or
developing a new business model is so
hard
so what falls in that category we got a
new competitor about six seven years ago
called open source software Linux
particularly different radically
different business model
I mean people could say was open source
innovative the number one innovation and
open sources is it's a very different
business model and if somebody came to
you in your jobs after you get out of
Business School and say hey you got a
new competitor that has no price and has
no cost structure you you might stay up
a night or two on that you really might
and you know so we we grew up with a
business model we had to learn to
embrace this enterprise model we had to
learn we couldn't embrace open source as
a business model how do you compete with
it
we're learning to break advertising it's
a radically different business model it
really is because you pay me for what I
do for you and so none of the connection
points that exist in other kinds of
businesses exist in an advertising
funded business the way that happens to
work so we've really wrapped our minds
around that so business models the
second thing which I also can do well on
is when things aren't going well on the
people front whatever that means
might mean somebody works for me he's
upset with me I mean you got to do what
you got to do but I really don't like
how many people upset with me at the end
of the day I worry about that when we
can't get two key people to really
collaborate in the right way whether
we're trying to recruit somebody and we
don't get them and when we lose somebody
and we don't lose many of our folks but
when we lose somebody who I don't want
to lose that kind of can get to me so
people related issues and tough business
model challenges don't keep me up at
night but they'd be that that kind of
thing okay let's see well ironically
there hasn't been really a software
standard software products or service
company other than perhaps Huawei that
really has emerged yet out of China and
India it's a question of time it's not a
in my opinion it's not but there are
some natural advantages to companies
that are based in developed markets it
turns out if you're based in the develop
market you actually have customers who
are have more money to buy from you and
you get more market feedback earlier in
the innovation cycle so even companies
that are starting in many other places
in the world tend to have a dual
headquarters of some form in the u.s.
it's interesting because people want to
make sure that they're in the feedback
loop that comes from the you know let's
say well financed customers here in the
largest developed market 60% of the
world's computer science graduates come
out of China and India now so it is
clear that there's a big opportunity for
us in the pursuit of the best talent to
recruit more people from those two
countries whether it's to recruit those
people to move someplace outside their
home country or to recruit them to live
in their home country with the current
issues which and I notice we have a
number of people here who've spoken with
non-us accents with the current issues
with h1
visas in a sense there is even more
pressure on any company that's trying to
get the world's best and brightest to
actually hold people in multiple parts
of the world and if you care about
computer science that really get you
looking very strongly Indian in China a
few months ago as a result Steven
Sinofsky who ran office is now over at
Windows and Steven Sinofsky is well
known for running a tight ship he and
he's pretty hands-on on the other hand
some people are concerned that
innovation might be stifled so I guess
my question is what do you think the key
challenges for Steven Sinofsky are being
on Windows right now and in general how
does their organizational structure
support innovation yeah let me kind of
give it a general flavor
the leaders are do have different skills
one question any business has to decide
is are we going to try to homogenize and
have one way we approach all problems
and I'm not actually making value
judgments I think it should be different
for different companies I don't think
there's a as much variation in the way
Walmart store managers run Walmart
stores as there is variation in the way
Microsoft R&D organizations run R&D and
I think that's to be expected in a
certain way and we have managers who are
much more systematic can they drive
innovation yes they can the person the
lady references is a guy who's a very
systematic thinker he's an engineer by
training he's taught some classes
actually at Harvard Business School
that's what he did on his sabbatical
very systematic thinker and people think
being systematic doesn't mean being
innovative and yet some of the most
innovative work we've done is the new
user interface in our office product
which quote his systematic approach
generated our newest billion-dollar
product is the thing called SharePoint
it's phenomenal it's a piece of
innovation that came out of the systemic
approach
there's also advantages to the non
systematic approach to innovation which
is more than a hallmark of our windows
group and all of these things can
produce the key is to at least in my
opinion in our company the key isn't to
quibble with the style that somebody
uses or the approach the key is to grade
the results and you just have to say are
these leaders are these teams are these
groups that produce products that just
aren't innovative but are innovative and
popular and we've had leaders who were
able to do that fairly successfully with
radically different styles across our
company
one more question right here number one
or number two
market share let me talk about I'll talk
about one that I think it's gonna be
huge
where shareholders could argue we were
investing too early but right now I'm
very pleased by that investment that's
the area of IP TV or TV that's going to
get delivered over tcp/ip internet style
networks we started working on TV over
Internet basically in about 1993 1994 we
were sure it was going to get super
red-hot super quickly we actually
acquired a little company at the time
down here for almost half a billion
bucks I think was almost half of thing
yeah I think that's right we write is
either 180 or 440 I can't remember right
now
I hope it was 180 anyway a company
called webtv and that's actually part of
the anchor pinnings of our Mountain View
campus and we just stayed at this notion
you know TV over IP connections is
really about two things one it's about a
an improved richer interactive TV
experience and two it is now becoming
the enabler that is allowing the
telephone companies basically to enter
the TV business in addition to the cable
company and so we've been at this thing
about 13 years and in some senses just
now we're really starting to see people
the Teleco telecom companies really get
after this is a serious proposition and
so whether it's AT&T or Verizon who are
working within the u.s. what you telecom
but this is something where basically we
had nascent Rd we did an acquisition ten
years ago so I consider that now all
nascent R&D basically we rolled it all
together we stayed persistent we stayed
patient everybody else who was around
the area went out of business went to do
something else and today I actually tell
you I think I think the our customers
are going to take a big share of the TV
business and the innovation will all be
innovation that builds on the innovation
in our IPTV platform so it's it's
another example where that's an example
again where can I argue we start we were
the first ones there were probably some
other guys in 94 also but we stayed
patient and persistent the SharePoint
product that I mentioned SharePoint was
a sort of a concept for a more
structured form of website that our guys
invented and today if you go to business
customers it's the hottest concept we
have out there with our office 2000 I
was just at a conference we had about
8,000 business partners and customers of
our of our ERP and CRM products together
in San Diego everybody is talking about
this SharePoint product because of the
innovation that it brings and it's a
category essentially that we created
scratch it's not a consumer category so
it gets a little less attention in the
popular press but man that's been a
successful innovation and a successful
march to to market so just a couple of
examples Steve I wish we had more time
but we don't let me say how wonderful it
is to have you back you're welcome back
anytime and I know everybody here joins
me in thanking you so much for sharing
[Applause]